when I started legal practice it was so
painful it was so slow I didn't have a
structure nobody told me hey you need to
do it this way or this way you need to
systemize it took me years to understand
every single business need to be
systemized otherwise it's not a business
you've just created yourself a job then
I joined the academy and things changed
how many rental rents do you currently
have three and how much profit do you
make or over the three
[Music]
Tatiana from Moscow making six figures
thanks for coming to my house thank you
for inviting me so tell me about what
you did before property what was your
occupation so before property I used to
work for different law firms and my last
Law Firm was a very large American law
firm and I absolutely hated it it's the
cold kind of corporate structure that
I'm too personable for it so I decided
to go it alone so to speak and after a
few years six or seven years being an
employee I set up my own Law Firm great
now I knew nothing about business how to
run business how to be director of a
business I just saw the need for people
to people who want to buy houses or
property and they want to use the money
they earned outside UK so foreign source
of funds and I knew all about it because
my clients used to be russian-speaking
clients mostly not anymore because now
we have clients from all over the world
but they do use funds to buy property
which they didn't earn here in this
country yeah so I saw the need and now
we set up a law firm which was a very
painful experience and was very slow
going because I knew nothing about it
you knew anything about about the
business aspect about the business
aspect because I was a property
solicitor so I was an employee yeah so
you knew all about being a property
lawyer but you didn't know how to
actually run the business run the
business or be a director of a company
or with all the responsibilities yeah
you know like all of a sudden I was
Employee with a paycheck coming in every
month and all of a sudden I was a
director and owner of a business and not
just any business a legal practice Yeah
and obviously English is not my first
language so it was very stressful very
slow going
um I had to pretty much work things out
as I was doing it
and I often think you know that if I
only knew them what I know now yeah
our legal practice would have become as
successful as it is now a lot earlier
how does your legal practice run now do
you have like members of staff that run
the run the show correct there is about
10 of us yeah and um solicitors
paralegals Finance people but I think
major point and particularly when I
joined the Academy I realized how
important it was I needed to step out of
the business because what I was doing
for many many years giving myself a job
right eight sounded glamorous I owned
the business but I still was involved
too much I was doing everything I almost
micromanaged people yeah and then you
learn as you go along then I joined the
academy and yeah and things changed so
people like you when you come to like
the crash course it's a bit it's a bit
nerve-wracking for me because you've got
this big legal practice you understand
property law like the back of your hands
you're running a business what did you
think when you first came to the crash
course and you saw what I was saying
about property it's very funny you
should say that because when I came
first of all I've canceled two crash
courses because my son introduced me to
you and said have you heard of this guy
Samuel Leeds I'm like no and he's like
well and we started watching your videos
and then he booked me on one crash
course and I was at the time I thought I
was too busy second crash course
canceled third crash course he said to
me right I booked you in you're going
and if you're not going I'm not speaking
to you for a month so I was like yeah
okay I'm going when you came through the
aisle I actually was completely
Starstruck because I watched you so much
on YouTube and everywhere else I was
like oh my God I literally that crash
course I hanged on every single what you
were saying by the end of it I was like
I want more of it so the crash course
was in October in November I attended
the four day course
and again it was intense a lot of
information a lot of energy and by the
end of it I was like I have to go for
the Academy I have to do it you have to
you know I was kind of a little bit like
because of course Academy cost money and
you know how you Ricky everybody who
talked to us on on these courses you
always say like if you really apply
yourself you will make that money back
I've made the money back the money I
paid for the Academy
in December I've made it back in January
literally a month later yeah wow it's
impressive how did you make it back so
quick what was the strategy well because
I was on a dual selling Extravaganza
course uh I was obviously managing the
practice legal practice and one of my
clients came up to me and said I've got
this couple of properties I want to sell
normally I would probably refer him to
one of these State agents we work with
but now I wasn't just property solicitor
I was a property entrepreneur hey so I
was like hold on a minute there is an
opportunity here yeah this is a deal
that if I find the buyer I can put them
together this is what we are taught
right so a little bit of work a little
bit of research and I found the buyer so
I helped to negotiate the deal between
my client who we help buying selling
houses on the legal side my legal firm
and then I found the buyer and put them
together helped to negotiate the deal
and close the deal as a result
I gave legal work to my law firm and
both parties paid me a commission for
the deal incredible what did you think
as a solicitor when you first heard the
concept of rent to rent because rent to
rent is something that sometimes people
that don't understand the law properly a
lot of people even estate agents they
say oh that's illegal so you being a
property lawyer would be interested what
was your first reaction when you heard
the business model it was exactly what
you've just said it was the property
solicitor in me vis-a-vis property
entrepreneur it's like as property
solicitors and I don't think I'm
generalizing we think well you have to
own property to make money out of
property right now here the strategy is
you don't have to own it you can control
it if you control it wisely and you
develop the business wisely you can earn
quite a lot of money from this strategy
so it was a bit of an eye-opener I said
I would say and then I've done a lot of
online I went through all of the online
training attended training in person
um and found my first landlord through
actually uh I can't remember that it was
a Gumtree or open Rand
but yeah I just literally just the email
to him I saw this property two-bedroom
house
and I contacted him
he replied and said well come and see
the property I didn't explain anything
about corporate let or rent to rent I
just literally made an appointment and
went to see him and when I came I just
chatted with him about myself about him
what is he all about about his property
and the property was pretty sort of run
down
so I asked him about that and then
slowly slowly I started introducing to
him this concept of rent to rent right
and I said well you know I can actually
refurb your property to absolutely
beautiful it will be beautiful because
I'm after really nice properties but the
location is amazing
so if I take control over your property
if I rent it off you then I will invest
some money make it look beautiful and
he's like oh well how does it work and
who is going to be living there and I
then I explained to him that I intend to
use it for a short short term let and
there will be guests some of my clients
some guests but the property will be and
I had to say the property will be on
Airbnb and then I twist it completely
the conversation and I started talking
about him and what he is going to get
guaranteed rent every month you don't
have any change of us you don't have any
tenancy agreements you have no
responsibility as a landlord
um you've just mentioned to me you want
to retire and go travel with your wife
that is exactly what I'm going to give
you he was a bit prickly in the middle
of the conversation by the end of it he
was like Tatiana are you sure it's all
true because it sounds a little bit too
good to be true I said you know what
whatever I promise you today I will
deliver every single promise and within
a week we signed I got three weeks rent
free and that's it and it's now three
years it's mine we already refurbished
it fully operational
and that's my first rent to rent
congratulations thank you how did how
much did you have to spend on the refurb
then what were the costs on the refurb I
spent about five thousand pounds it's a
big refurb yeah but I mean it's not
refurbed it's it's cosmetic but it
needed it because I really wanted to
achieve full occupation how long have
you had that that property for now we
signed the agreement beginning of May
right it took us about six weeks to
refurb and then uh
end of June we went live so how much
profit is it making at the moment per
month overall we've got a few properties
now because we're added that particular
property uh between 800 1000 pound a
month very good very good yeah and
you've then got a bunch more rent to
rent finds more entrance and overall it
now the business because you look you
have to look at it as a business that's
again teachings of the academy yeah you
can't just take a property and then just
work with a landlord add another
property you've got to take it as a
business and run it as a business I
realized once I've done it systemizing a
business is just um a key to make rent
to rent a success how many rental rents
do you currently have three and how much
profit do you make over the three four
thousand pound a month that's big and
how much money did you have to put in
all together across the three adjust
that five thousand oh so that's five
thousand is for all of them no well not
for them I didn't have to put in any
money into the other properties okay I
only into the first one because it was
really run down and then the first one
presumably you used that as a bit of a
foot in the door to get the others
because you say look this is what I'm
doing for this landlord this is how good
the property looks you're going to have
glowing references from him and of
course we had before and after pictures
as well pictures and videos because the
property really was in in a bad State
first it was almost a race to get
properties to start operating this
business but then I thought you know
everything I've been learning in the
academy and my experience with the legal
practice okay I need to systemize it and
now I am not really involved in the
business only when I need to it kind of
works by itself how many hours a week do
you have to spend working to get that
four thousand pounds a month
couple of hours wow so you've really
systemized it yeah I it's the key and I
think another
lesson not also from rent to rent apart
from being just completely uh
overwhelmed with how well it can work
when you don't actually own a property
or just control control a property but
also you need to be an absolute superb
Problem Solver because problems will
arise in in rent-to-end strategy I don't
know if you had but we had this
situation where we had a party we spoke
about it we did you messaged me on
Instagram about it we did we did we had
a party without our knowledge in in the
two-bedroom house I don't think it got
out of hand but the neighbor downstairs
we have a neighbor downstairs who
complained about the noise
to her landlord to our landlord to the
estate agent and to the local Council
and it's now this is two or three weeks
into us being live we're completely new
to it yeah and I wake up in the morning
I go to my uh place of work I switch my
computer on and I've got all this angry
emails from everyone and I'm like oh my
god what happened immediately you think
it's the end of the world but actually
it's how you deal with those situations
contacted everybody immediately I
emailed our landlord back and I called
him back and I explained to him that
we're going to put certain things in
place like noise monitors like
um asking IDs from guests so we know who
is actually staying in our properties
yeah and we have a strict no party's
policy I explained it all to him I'm
really fearing now on the phone that he
is about to tell me do you know what
Tatiana you promised me a lot and this
is what happened he said to me the way
you handled this
was beautiful I have no doubt you will
look after my property really well right
you know what don't worry about it it
shows that problems will come but it's
not about the prop when they come it's
about how you handle it 100
it definitely you have to be a brilliant
problem solver
um and you have to systemize it we
already said that yeah and I think also
you need to stand out I give you an
example we had like High season a really
good bookings really good income we
really had a really a good run over
summer
now come September uh kids went to
school and bookings slowed down we
looked at the property and we decided to
uplift it a little so we put some quirky
signs on the walls for example in the
bedroom like wake up to a beautiful day
or things like that or in in the sitting
room in the kitchen
bought some nice lights we put behind
the television so a guest actually can
with remote control switch the lights on
and it makes this at you know a really
nice atmosphere yeah and we kind of look
at the property now it's not High season
anymore people won't come drop their
bags and go to to the beach so now it's
more the feel and look of a cozy night
in now it's autumn and winter and the
last sort of cherry on the cake if you
want we bought a PlayStation
and we bought a really nice shelves like
this television nice shelves first shelf
remote controls the second shelf uh
Playstation a couple of bean bags just
couple lights behind the television and
new pictures new photographs yeah and
all of a sudden it's no longer seasonal
just nice location nice property it's
now you look at the pictures and it's
now oh ASCO that's nice right yeah so I
think yeah that's that's the left so you
have to remember the season you're in
the market that you're tapping into and
and Market it properly and accordingly
to the right season and if you just said
oh it's all passive it's systemized and
you'd have just turned away from it the
bookings would have dried up yes I
believe so yeah yeah that's incredible
so you've done deal selling you made
your money back within the first four
weeks correct from packaging and selling
deals correct
um you've also making you're making
foreground a month from rent to rent
what what are you doing now what what
what what what deals have you got going
on at the moment so we're still doing it
but it's almost systemize the legal
practice the rent to rent is a second
business which we systemized and now I'm
moving to the third business which I
want to add to my portfolio and that's
Land Development yeah I didn't have
confidence before to do it now I'm
beginning to understand what I'm dealing
with and property and I'm beginning to
look at property Market as property
entrepreneur not blinkers property
solicitor yeah so now I'm ready and
confident to move to
something a little bit bigger a little
bit more complex yeah so I went further
for a development Deep dive yeah two
days and that was incredible because
that's again it's it's a lot more
private because there's only few of us I
don't know there was what 15 20 people
there yeah and of course it's all the
explanation and training but then it's
like do it yourselves now you've got
your tablets your laptops do it on the
second day I was chatting with Anna Anna
and Elliot and we were like just
exchanging ideas and going like okay
patch which patch I don't know in my
patch like say Brighton or even where I
leave London or Kent I know Kent we
couldn't I couldn't find anything so we
started exchanging ideas and then Elliot
said well there is a lot of land for
development in where I live I said where
do you live Shropshire and we found a
piece of land we did our due diligence
and we realized that the land the
neighboring land is owned by the same
guy and that land is already under
development so we've done a little bit
more due diligence and we realized we
can build there up to 11 bungalows right
so we had the looks done our numbers and
literally like few States maybe on the
map there is a very similar development
already built and it's over a million
pound uh worth of gdv
so we calculated that we can make an
offer I would like to make an offer for
this piece of land of about four hundred
thousand pounds yeah so we now know that
there is a piece of land we know who
owns it we know neighboring land is also
owned by this guy and it's already under
development so of course as part of the
training we use the script and we write
the letter we wrote a letter and I
posted it last week
to the landowner
so we will see if he comes back to us
then we will see what we can do with
that but that that's the potential
leadership the process of how to do it
how to find land how to work out whether
you can get planning how much it's going
to cost to build what the end value is
correct amazing so that's kind of your
main focus now all in two days yeah well
we don't mess about doing it no you
don't but of course I also I can't stop
halfway can I so I also joined the
development Mastermind yeah amazing so
that's you go from a big group like uh
buy refurbishly Finance part of the
academy then you go to a smaller group
um development Deep dive about 20 maybe
30 people over there
now you go even to a smaller group which
will now give me more private mentoring
uh and uh oh I have already spoken to
Tony who was brilliant he said okay
first think first what do you want out
of it I said I want third business we
already have two I have third business
and I want to scale it up and I want to
get involved and possibly even involve
my investors who I have so now you've
got your law practice which you've
systemized you've got your property
entrepreneurship which is rent to rent
deal selling which you're systemizing
and still growing because I know you've
got more more problems coming and now
you've got your property development
business correct which is going to be
your you know your your wealth building
correct absolutely incredible wow what
does your son think of all this because
it was only what nine months ago when it
when he sent you along to the crash
course what does he think about what
you've achieved to be honest with you he
has known me all his life so he kind of
knows what I'm like I was never going to
stop at crash course I was never going
to stop it for the development course or
deal selling I mean if you do it you
can't do property halfway particularly
if you have an opportunity like I do now
with property Mastermind
to have one-to-one with Russell with
Tony with other guys who is in the group
this is an opportunity to learn from the
best why would I stop now yeah so he he
kind of he's I think he's proud of me
but I don't think he's surprised at all
and also as well as part of the academy
we always say because the academy as you
know isn't in before we take anybody on
we always interview people and see if
they'll be a good fit and part of the
academy is it's not just what you can
get it's also what you can give and
you've been a absolutely unindicted from
other Academy members asking you legal
questions yeah it kind of started very
um well strangely if I can if that's the
right word I literally just like maybe
five six months ago when I started
obviously people get to know each other
and everybody learned that I was a
property solicitor I don't think many
people knew that it's actually my
practice and when they find out it's
like oh can you help me so I basically
literally as a volunteer Tia helped
couple of people those couple of people
told another couple of people those
couple of people told the nazica and now
I literally spend every single evening
at least an hour to hours on the phone
or checking the contracts or telling
them what needs to be deleted or various
things various things well that's very
good of you to do that and you really
don't have to but it's it's you've been
a huge asset to the academy and we're
very grateful for that and you know it's
and that's what we are we're a property
family and we just you know help each
other out what's been the biggest
hardship was there ever a time when you
thought this is not worth it it's too
much it's too much effort I don't think
there was any point where I thought why
am I doing it no no I know why I'm doing
it and I want to go all the way there
were a couple of moments where everybody
has those moments in the academy in
property where you feel like well it's
been like two three weeks I haven't done
anything I'm trying but nothing sort of
you know there's no success there is no
replies there is no yeses I just
possibly keep going keep going keep
going yeah and it will all come and also
as well with your law practice because
you're you know on quite a high hourly
rate for you to give up a couple of days
and come to a course you're also losing
money because of your time so that's why
we run the programs very Punchy very to
the point we go on late because if
people are booking a couple of days of
work and we do a nine to five with with
a with an hour and a half lunch break
and breaks all the way yeah suddenly you
know unless unless that people haven't
got a job you want it to be really good
don't you on the program and I think I
think we do a pretty good job of that I
think the training is has been good yeah
it's very intense and the amount of the
amount of information I learned the the
skills information is one thing but then
skills how to do things even how to look
at property differently is like immense
immense I remember studying at
University for four years and I don't
think I've learned at University uh of
over four years as much as I've learned
in the past seven months wow that's a
nice big statement that that is true
because here
you listen you learn from different
people different mentors but you also do
you have to do because you are hold
accountable exactly and I think as a
coach you know I kind of have to read
people because sometimes people need an
arm around them and sometimes people
need yeah a big punch in the face you
know like yeah come on like a wake-up
call and it's about reading people and
knowing basically how to work with each
individuals in order to get them over
the line over the 12 months what would
you say to somebody that was wanting to
start out in in in property that maybe
was it was a lawyer or had a
professional background and was wanting
to transition over to the business side
of actually being an investor or an
entrepreneur what advice would you give
do it first of all absolutely do it
because it completely opened up the
entire new world for me that crash
course that I went the third one that I
couldn't miss changed my life and you
paid how much to go one pound yeah they
can't argue with that one pound you know
I used to think before Academy
or before even crash course let's go
back
that 20 15 20 000 in the bank for
example I'm just any figure it's nice
little rounded sum but then all of the
training everything I've done so far
completely changed my not changed my
mind uh just Twisted it all and put it
upside down that ten thousand is a waste
of money invest it in yourself go and
learn how to do things properly if
you're lucky enough get in with the
right mentors in the right environment
and then just follow the basic rules the
teachings and Implement yeah you you
have to implement you know like some
people say I'm not really being
successful here I've done all the online
videos and I was like well what have you
done what action did you take you have
to just do it do it do it yeah action
what is your reason for all of this
what's the strongest reason that keeps
you going it gives you that fire to get
where I believe I can get
but with the right mentoring shape with
the in the right environment because
I've been
um
working on the legal side with the legal
firm for over 10 years
I should have been and I and I probably
would have been very successful there a
lot earlier as as we're successful now
if I was in the right environment so I
just want to see how far I can go now I
am in the right environment it makes
sense well your your future is so bright
it burns my eyes and what you've done so
far is is incredible and I can thank you
you can do in seven years if you've done
what you've done in seven months so yes
thank you for your
um support thank you for the time today
coming to inspire people from a lawyer's
perspective thank you and also for
giving back in the academy in the way
that you do we really appreciate that
thank you
[Music]